we all think we know what numbers are we
use them every day
but very quickly you get into some real
mathematical questions that aren't
buried at the end of some course they're
right on the surface
hi my name is Paige bright and I'm a
junior studying mathematics at MIT and
I'll be your guest host for today's
episode of chalk radio
for this episode I sat down with
Professor Haynes Miller
I'm a professor now emeritus of
mathematics at MIT I got here in 1986 a
long time ago I've taught a lot of
subjects to undergraduates especially
1803 differential equations and I hope
we have a chance to talk about that
that's who I am
I first met with Haynes when he was my
instructor for a special first year
seminar at MIT I'll let Haynes tell you
more about these seminars he facilitated
MIT has a wonderful series of classes
called first year advising seminars
these are small seminars maybe eight
students the seminar that you and I were
in page was unusual because this was the
first fall of the pandemic so it was
entirely remote very interesting we had
many time zones represented one student
was calling in from Vietnam another from
Kuwait another from Nepal and places in
the U.S and it was the most successful
seminar that I've run because it was a
chance for students to interact on a
personal level with their peers even
though they were halfway across the
world
one of the most important aspects of
these first year advising seminars is
his focus on communication and
Mathematics the seminars start by asking
a simple question that hooks and
mathematicians of any background like
how do you define symmetry or what is a
number and in the end covers complex
mathematical topics like modulus bases
and surreal numbers
part of what makes haynes's classes so
compelling is his focus on the ways we
communicate as mathematicians
in a way I envy my engineering
colleagues because they produce
artifacts they produce actual physical
things and my lab science colleagues do
the same thing they interact in
complicated ways with the world
mathematicians all we have is
communication all we have is the writing
that we do we publish and we try to
explain our ideas and there isn't any
physical object that we produce so
communicating is the whole game in
mathematics in a way
given that communicating math is so
integral in haynes's teaching and
research I was curious how he thinks
about it what's his approach
whenever you're writing or communicating
the the main thing is to keep your
audience in mind who are you talking to
where are they what is their background
interest uh why are they there what is
their background knowledge and when
you're teaching that's Paramount
importance so when I was teaching
differential equations 1803 I always had
in mind that I was teaching mainly
engineers and there were some science
majors and some math majors in my
audience but for them this was often as
close to an engineering course as they
were going to see here at MIT so I tried
very hard to use engineering language in
fact one of the things that I would do
was to invite an engineer into the
classroom one day during the semester
and we would talk the talk with each
other we'd use the language that we'd
been developing in the class and it
became clear to the students that this
was real this was the language that
Engineers used of course the engineers
always knew much more about the kind of
systems and signals language than I was
talking about so I formed a kind of
translating device between the students
who knew little and the engineers who
knew a great deal
so let's talk for a minute about this
class that Hans is referring to
differential equations or 1803 the study
of differential equations is the study
of how small changes in a function or
derivatives impact the function itself
for instance how does heating a metallic
Rod at one point affect the temperature
of the rod everywhere
in a class like 1803 one hopes to
systematically understand these types of
problems but Haynes has a bit of a
different approach to teaching
differential equations one that changes
how students think about functions as a
whole
students come into a differential
equations course and they've seen
calculus and they're getting used to the
idea of a function but still for many of
them a function it's a complicated thing
it has many parts there's many input
values and each one has an output value
it's a complicated thing and what
happens in the course of a differential
equations course is you come to think of
a function as a single thing it's a
composite thing it has smaller parts but
you think of it as a single object
that process of collecting a group of
things and coalescing them into a single
object that's a fundamental mathematical
operation that you can see in action
already very clearly in a differential
equations course and it's one of the
main skills that I hope students Come
Away with from taking a course like this
they think of a function as a single
object that you can manipulate you can
compare two of them because one is the
derivative of another or they enter into
a differential equation together
foreign
get too deep into the math here I want
to take a minute to focus on haines's
Innovative approach to teaching I asked
him about how he makes math not just
comprehensible but also engaging for
students
we human beings are most of us are
equipped we're all equipped with a
visual cortex we're all equipped with an
extremely highly developed elaborate and
sophisticated visual system even if
we're blind that system is still at work
in our brain it's still available in our
brain and what does it do
an infant looks around in the world and
sees a million pixels sees a million
spots of color
but one of the first operations that an
infant performs in growing up is
learning the notion of an object putting
together a collection of pixels and
seeing that they constitute an object
that has its own identity so that our
visual cortex is really well suited to
doing exactly this operation of
assembling things and seeing them as a
single unit it's it's a special feature
that we have in our brain so one of the
things that I did to help students make
this step in the differential equations
course was to create a series of
computer manipulatives I call them
programs you can find them on the web at
mathlets.org and they display functions
as units and they show how the functions
will change when you change parameters
they show you the relationship between
functions that participate in a
differential equation
and I think that for many students
seeing the graph visually seeing the
graph of a function is a huge asset in
making them see a see this as a single
object
and keeping with his work helping
students visualize differential
equations Haynes noticed that there was
a big part of the academic experience
that was missing a mathematical element
Beyond visualization lab work
MIT has a general Institute requirement
all undergraduates are required to take
a course that has a designation as a lab
course
historically mathematics didn't have a
lab course the the wisdom was that how
could you have a laboratory in
mathematics there is no artifact but I
felt that mathematics is a science we
employ the scientific method we collect
data perhaps by doing examples perhaps
by computer we form hypotheses maybe we
call them conjectures and we try to get
evidence for them our evidence typically
is called a proof
there's not a bench with lab equipment
on it that people are working on
together but there is the Blackboard or
the Whiteboard or the tablet these days
and of Zoom where people are are working
in parallel
so together with his colleague in the
math department Professor Michael arton
Haynes pulled together a series of small
open-ended research projects that
undergraduate students could work on to
fulfill their lab requirement in a math
focused environment this led to the
creation of a class entitled the project
laboratory in mathematics
it's a very high communication kind of
course but it also gives a pretty honest
introduction to the research process in
mathematics it's something that's been
useful for students who come to it never
having engaged in any kind of research
before it opens their eyes to the notion
that not everything is a textbook
exercise and for people who have had
research experience it's even there also
it's a great training in teamwork and in
writing in communicating
one part of my conversation with Haynes
that I really loved was this explanation
of how teaching these courses led to his
own understanding of what goes into
effective mass communication
after I got involved with these
communication intensive subjects I
became much more aware of the sort of
stylistic issues in mathematics writing
and I have to say I became a much more
severe editor and reviewer and worked
quite hard to help the author use
language correctly and be more careful
about Their audience because it's very
common you know in mathematics to begin
a paragraph with a statement that comes
out of the blue
because there's an image that we're
struck by lightning and we have this
inspiration this of course not true
there's a big background to that there's
a lot of a lot of preparation that goes
into that and writing should be the same
way you build up to a point
and then you connect you make the next
step
hence it's been collaborating with Susan
Ruff a lecturer in writing across the
curriculum who has been working with the
mathematics department and the project
lab for many years now
Susan Ruff is very clear on the
importance of what she calls
connectivity which is to say you don't
introduce a lot of new Concepts
simultaneously you begin where the last
sentence ended and you may take the next
step and when you think of writing
mathematics writing in that way you
really improve the comprehensibility of
the writing so I think that my work as
an editor and as a reviewer of math
papers has really been influenced by the
communication intensive teaching that
I've been involved with here
hence his clear intention to constantly
be improving his teaching is truly
remarkable
one way he's helped both himself and
other instructors develop their teaching
skills is through a program he created
and hosts called the online seminar on
undergraduate mathematics education or
ulsum
so about six years ago or so I was
sitting in a coffee shop with a former
postdoc Grace Leo from the math
department here and she was making the
point that you research universities
like Stanford where she was employed at
the time at MIT where she used to be
employed the professors there think hard
about teaching
but
they don't talk to each other very much
about their thoughts about teaching we
really don't talk too much with each
other normally within a given faculty
about teaching so we thought well there
are these few campuses maybe we should
have a meeting together but it occurred
to me that we have zoom which existed
back before covid believe it or not and
we could do this remotely and start up a
monthly seminar every two weeks actually
seminar asking faculty to talk about the
teaching initiatives that they'd engaged
in in their own campus sometimes it was
a specific different way of grading
sometimes it was a different way of
organizing basic courses sometimes it
was interacting with Engineers to
optimize the basic courses that the math
department was offering
and we've been running it every two
weeks during the Academic Year ever
since it's become quite a useful
resource I think my original thought
that there was a lot of activity going
on around the country in different
departments with a lot of imagination
and creativity and passion it was true
and we have it we have it on record now
archived and available at the Olsen
website
on top of teach ER friendial equations
course and running the project lab
Haynes also runs the first year seminars
that we mentioned earlier
the title of the seminar I was in was
titled what is a number and while you
might be surprised that a math major
would take a class titled what is a
number it's actually a rather
fascinating question we all think we
know what numbers are we use them every
day but very quickly you get into some
real mathematical questions that aren't
buried at the end of some course they're
right on the surface and you realize for
example that you can't really answer
that question what is a number it
doesn't make sense in itself you can
answer a question like what is a number
system
because the whole point about numbers is
how they relate to each other so we get
back to this issue about things forming
complexes things forming combinations
before they really have meaning that was
one of the most interesting and fun
things about the seminar that we were in
was thinking carefully about the concept
of number and the many different
varieties of numbers that there are but
every time every one of them you see
that it doesn't make sense until you
think of them in a system
other mathematical Concepts that came
out very clearly was the notion that you
get at something by characterizing its
properties
so I guess this is the axiomatic system
you gain much better insight into what
an integer is
by thinking about it axiomatically what
are the properties that you expect that
number system to have you can construct
them in different ways but every single
construction of them is artificial
and in a sense irrelevant because in the
end you're just using their properties
so this is a very deep mathematical
perspective actually that came out quite
clearly right away without a great deal
of background and it was accessible to
freshmen pretty easily
hands is truly dedicated to helping
people understand complex and
intimidating subjects
he also cares about crafting his
materials in a way that gets students
thinking differently and there's one
seminar where this certainly comes to
fruition the Khan seminar
so Dan Khan was a faculty member here he
was here when I got here he's now
deceased
he ran a graduate course but he declined
to lecture
instead he had students lectured and
this was a revolutionary concept I think
when it began back in about 1965.
the Cannes seminar has been in action
every fall ever since then run by him
first and then by other people and then
for a number of years by me now it's
passed on to other people
it's a literature seminar on the classic
papers in this subject algebraic
topology
and it gives students it gives this
graduate students and now increasingly
undergraduates from from MIT and from
Harvard will take it it gives them a
chance to appreciate how the subject
developed
and to really learn the basic examples
that are still motivating the subject
today
it gives students a chance to talk to a
faculty member regularly I talk with
each student every week about the paper
that they're going to present and learn
to read a paper in two ways they learn
to read a paper in great detail because
they're going to give a talk about it
they have to understand it and they will
pick some part of the paper that they
think is especially interesting and they
want to tell their peers about
but also they're expected to read the
papers that everybody else is talking
about so they also learn to read a paper
very quickly and get something useful
from it very efficiently
I was curious about how we had students
teach the lectures
Haynes told me a bit about his own
Beginnings as an instructor and also how
he gets students to present in ways that
are both engaging and useful to others
I remember when I first got here I was
videotaped as many beginning teachers
are here and I watched the video of
myself teaching and I thought why is
this guy trying to act so cool and why
doesn't he just say things like they are
and so I learned to be a mortar act from
that experience
a tendency to assume that everybody in
their audience knows everything they're
going to say
and so they'll rush through it they'll
not do an adequate job in explaining
what they have to say because they think
there's no point this is just a
formality of some kind so really
persuading them that
they're saying something that
the audience doesn't know and it's up to
them to explain it that's that's a big
deal
[Music]
to close our episode today I wanted to
share some Reflections from Haynes about
ocw having personally worked on some
course content for open courseware I can
say that it's an amazing experience to
get to make materials to help Educators
and students alike learn from the
amazing resources at MIT regardless of
where they are or what academic Avenues
are available to them
the MIT faculty are so incredibly lucky
to have open courseware as a as a
conduit as a way of expressing
yourselves as a way of publishing this
work that we do that we spend a great
part of our professional life working on
other universities don't have that
luxury typically they don't have a way
to memorialize and contribute their
teaching work to the World At Large it's
it's such a great resource that we have
here one of the great things about ocw
is you run the course and then they tell
open courseware to go run with it and
something amazing happens
[Music]
Professor Miller shares additional
thoughts on the courses talked about
today such as the Khan seminar and the
project lab in mathematics on ocw
it can views these resources at
ocw.mit.edu
you can also learn more about his work
with the online seminar on undergraduate
mathematics education or alsoom at
olsume.org
thank you so much for listening to this
guest podcast until next time I'm Paige
bright from MIT opencourseware
MIT chalk radios producers include Sarah
Hansen Brett patchy and Dave leshansky
show notes for this episode were in my
peter Chipman we're funded by Amity open
learning and supporters like you